Mexican health authorities are warning
the country's health system could become
overwhelmed by the spread of COBIT 19
this week Mexico's deputy Health
Minister called for a voluntary 30-day
isolation period and declared a national
public health emergency esta is la
última por Tunisia
this is our last chance to avoid
contagion or we cannot limit the
epidemic we do not want to live in the
situation that other countries are
facing in Brazil concerns are growing
that Public Health Services could
collapse by the end of April as the
number of Kovach 19 infections continues
to grow
authorities in Rio have begun
repurposing schools and event spaces to
tend to the most vulnerable like the
city's homeless population is the
Spanish possio Parliament this space
will be for sheltering those who accept
being protected from coronavirus because
this population is the most vulnerable
in the streets they are very exposed in
Latin America calls for self isolation
as the best defense against kovat 19 are
intensifying in Cuba a lockdown is in
effect until at least the end of April
and only citizens or foreign residents
are being allowed into the country all
travelers arriving from abroad are sent
to a quarantine Center for a period of
two weeks I live in the United States
but I came as soon as I saw how the
problem with coronavirus was being
handled because this is my country where
my family is and I have more confidence
in the public health system here than
anywhere else at least a dozen Latin
American countries have imposed
mandatory quarantines to fight contagion
authorities in Mexico however say they
do not intend to enforce that people
stay home a policy that could change
given the relaxed attitude many here
have over the viral threat manoeuvrable
o al Jazeera Mexico City